as the digital equivalent of the dilemma
of the chicken and the egg which came
first okay right and as as confusing as
that the reason it's called
bootstrapping is it comes from an old an
old tale of literally pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps so the ways in
which you'd actually get something
started attitude who we are so hot we
think that's right
and that bootstrapping sequence is the
thing that starts that process one of
the hardest bets of doing computing is
yet ultimately have to recognize that
comes a moment when you can understand
it all you can understand the thing that
you're building is so complex the it
doesn't all fit in your head okay that's
the hardest and most difficult moment I
face I've ever faced and it's the bet
that everybody can I do in computing
struggles with hand to me when I learn
about compilers okay know compilers are
the things which take the programming
languages that we have and translate
that programming language into the
sequence of instructions that run at the
chip on the computer okay so they go all
the way from the kind of high level
language like Java down to the machine
codes that you may be running on here's
what it kind of gets difficult and this
is where we're well you're gonna have to
bear with me on this one and as the
digital equivalent of the dilemma of the
chicken and the egg which came first
okay
right and as I as confusing as that okay
and so you will rate something in a
language let us let us say for example
you rate something and when the
languages we would use would be Java and
you rate things in Java and it has a
protector austell of rating F you know F
statements a whole set of things how did
you start with the first language come
from and how did you get there it is
that moment of complexity that it almost
feels like magic okay
because it works and a teacher well to
figure out why it works and it feels
quite a list of bootstrapping is is a
means by which we can allow our software
systems to exist and dependent of the
machines that they run not without
things like bootstrapping
and without compilers you'd essentially
have to rewrite programs and replicate
all the instructions for every machine
that you'd ever build okay or every
family of machines so if you if
everything stayed at the level of ones
and zeros and flaking switches
you'd have to have a different sequence
of flesh and switches for every machine
that exists in the world and that gets
tiresome at best but virtually
impossible given the complexities in the
size of God so that's why would that be
the case professor because if the same
computer has been made twice at the
Apple factory and all the circuits
exactly the same and everything exactly
the same so wouldn't this wouldn't the
language that worked on computer a still
work on computer B that would that would
potentially be okay but then let's put
in a PC made by multiple manufacturers
and multiple sorts and manufacturers but
then let's think about that same program
running on an another machine or another
architecture so that would also mean
that every program that you'd make our
run would have to be rewritten when you
bought your next machine or the change
that upgraded it so it becomes
incredibly complex to do this and and in
trend the convoys and and frankly fee
was just a little bit dumb yeah right
okay so so so something betters needed
than that and what we what happened in
computing is this notion of what was
called high-level languages got but
developed a high level languages are
languages which free you from the
monotony of those switches and free you
from thinking in ones and zeros and let
you think and in a more abstract way
okay and the abstraction that's applied
here as often thing as often
for anyone who programs is fairly
familiar Ed's and F statements its
iteration it's so these are the means by
which we think of our programmers so our
programmers know rate in these languages
and they don't ever really have to think
about what those things run on okay they
simply need to think algorithmically on
those languages you need to find a way
of expressing that higher-level language
and mapping that higher-level language
to the ones and zeros that drive your
machine and a number of people Bell Bell
a sequence of of systems that they're
done people that Devan thought no we're
rating programs here in this
higher-level language and those programs
can do mostly anything one of the things
that those programs when this
higher-level language could do if you
wrote them as they could actually do
that translation they could written in
that higher-level language I actually do
the translation from the higher-level
language to the lower level language the
next step once you've done that is you
can identify a small core subset of the
language that represents the very candle
starting point to let that process
become happen okay so that so that's
small paint and and the tactic here is
to make that the smallest that you
possibly can okay so that's smoke tiny
candle is the starting point for you to
be able to compile and run a program and
then that can compile and run the
compiler they can let you do a bigger
and bigger set of languages and so
somewhat snow happen is you've got a
small program that if you translate that
small program and from one machine
architecture to another okay that will
then run those other programs translate
those other things and then everything
that's ever been written in that
higher-level language can run in your
new machine so the only thing that has
to be
from machine to machine is this little
tiny nugget this and that and that
pulsar and that little seat and the
means by which you then pull those other
things over to let everything run is
it's called the bootstrap and it comes
from the phrase pulling yourself up by
your bootstraps and that bootstrap
process is the bet that does the
translation from one machine to another
so that kind of nother a nut or central
point is the bottom it's a base level
for all these kind of terrors of
abstraction okay and in operating
systems that often gets referred to as
they cannot care no sono operating
systems it would be the thing that
touches the hardware so it would be the
thing that puts things and in off desks
where it'd be the things that speaks to
it varies just the displays and so those
are that candle as the chemist starting
point for it so Bruce wraps is the
principle by which you do this candles
is the way what is the particular name
given from our sequence in some
operating systems there are potato
stands applied and it's done in
particular ways actually one of the
things that's really interesting is what
goes in there stays in there okay and
and so and it stays in there forever
but is it because that's it's hard to
change that wave of cording
most developers had to read 600 pages
per day of change requests before they
could do any coding that's called
popping a stack